[Music]
good morning morning look I think an IRA
twinning today we totally didn't do it
on purpose
no we really didn't he changed first and
then I put this on Mel dick hey we're 20
you love this dance right now anyway so
today is pretty exciting our friend Ken
he's a dancer he's from this dance group
called poreotics anyway he's a really
close friend of ours so he's coming over
to teach Isaac how to dance
are you excited what are you looking
forward to
did you see some actual moves not the
just the same ones that you know so
about a month or two ago there was this
pool party at our friend aunt's house
and then Ken was there and then Ken was
teaching him some moves like she does
like really unique style of dancing I
don't know what it's called so I'm a
dancer but he taught him some of it I
guess today they're gonna finish up
learning this routine and then Ken's
gonna record a music video sort of thing
so we're gonna get that going today and
then later on tonight I am going to a
concert with my mama and I want to bring
you guys with me I'm not sure who we're
gonna go see but they're like these
Latino artists I don't know we'll find
out later camp here
oh my hi Bri you're so slow we're good
welcome are you ready to dance Isaac
yeah nice you look so fly dude Thanks
these are
yeah I'm gonna teach Isaac some tutting
today and that's like my main style of
dance oh that's it it's called
yeah tutting and I think Isaac's pretty
excited to learn because I kind of
showed him a couple of moves but we're
gonna review some of them today and then
we're going to dance to an actual song
exciting dancing though tutting this
one's the boy he's the one that's really
extra friendly the girl is like hiding
somewhere and Maya's really shy do you
apply
no he's super friendly look at the
Hickey just that time I made can't open
to like getting a cat yesterday he's
like yeah I think she's having a cat
really
so is Franklin your dog and then a
little cat and queen in a cat Oh cute
Isaac oh those are half jacks I've never
heard of that
that sounds well you're stretching your
arm yeah oh you're pretty flexible way
how far can you pull it dang dude he
could do a 45-degree angle that he got
that for me crazy look at this that's
for sure from me like to my know he goes
up to 90 but here's this it goes like
all the way back see that's why it's
good to start dancing when you're
younger yeah it's definitely more
flexible Wow I'll look at that that's
crazy dude cool I need to be a pro
tighter
oh yeah I can do it too am I pretty okay
[Music]
you want to look like you know the
Egyptian oh that word tutting so yeah
you ever see those hieroglyphics in
Egypt where they're just walking like
this yeah yeah yeah oh that makes so
much more sense now cuz I did wonder
like where did tutting come from there's
no cute he's freaking out my god I'm
playing I'm cute I never seen him do
that with anyone other than Maya he only
dilemma Maya
[Music]
you know we have a friend that's a
breakdancer yeah do you remember Vince
you've met him well Vince can teach you
breakdancing next after now that you've
mastered tutting dude you're so lucky
you have so many times with people
around you how do you feel about it do
you think you could do the better or do
you want to do the deals are you okay
with it
[Music]
[Music]
no you did a cat meow a cameo you know
but um this is his first dance me yeah
he's never done whatever yeah your
freestyle was pretty good man because
most kids his age are kind of afraid of
dancing by themselves yeah cuz it's like
it's like a confidence thing you know a
lot confidence that's good whoa that's
awesome here I'm so proud of you too you
don't have any idea how proud I am of
you right now I'm also proud this is my
star pupil yeah you're posting this
video on your Instagram yeah I've been
posting videos everyday Instagram and
he's gonna be a part of that journey
well thanks for coming over
yeah no problem alright so my mom just
got here she's parking in the garage
right now KC is not here because he went
out to have a meeting with friends about
working on a music video that they've
been working on for a while so that's
the reason why Casey's not here but my
mom just got here which is really
exciting because I never get to see her
that often she lives about an hour away
I know it's not that far away but she
has her own life and like you know we
get caught up on our own life so it's
really nice to spend some time with her
so she won these concert tickets on the
radio and I'm not too sure who the
artists are but like somebody gets on
artists and stuff hi mama
yes see how are you you look so pretty
thank you sorry yeah you're just coming
in and I put on your Facebook yeah can
you remind me who who's the artist
so much Stan Jaffa Sebastian yatra and
Manuel booty soul yes so those are the
people were gonna go see so you want
these tickets on the radio wait enough
Kayla I love the number 10 um however is
the first time I tried it
Oh what's wrong Oh how are you you going
so fast
thank you oh my gosh I know you go
zipped all of you you treat how are you
man good good yeah yeah we've been
working on the project oh yeah that's
the project right here do you want
telangana what the project about so we
have to be like engineers we need a bill
like a water system mm-hmm explaining
how it goes from the mountain
so this is the mountain to the lake and
into the Lego village skyscraper city
and then here's like the water treatment
center like the pump or the what is it
called a water tower yeah there you go
water tower so we built this last night
it was pretty cool because they told us
not to buy anything for this project so
we just pulled things around from the
house we just made this happen to like
the way this works you pump this thing
and then it'll travel through the straw
to the water bottle and that's water
bottle of the water tower for the
village so yeah we need to finish it
though right
you need to add some like grass and just
paint like make it look nice yeah right
right you did yeah bring me a brush
shoot you're you actually have it
wait what videos this is the last one oh
my god you baptism my baptism video you
know what that's crazy cuz I remember
when I was 15 years old I spent my 15th
birthday
in Mexico and they gave me this VHS tape
and I put it in the luggage and that
luggage was lost forever and I thought
that I lost this forever so it's kind of
weird that you have it how do you have
it I have it I don't know maybe it's a
copy maybe it is but I just remember
thinking like no my baptism video is
going forever and I'm never gonna have
it that's so crazy Wow thank you mom I
got another surprise for you what
another surprise yeah oh my goodness
what else what else what else well
remember the wedding a year ago yeah for
you thank you mom oh my gosh the menus
from our wedding for your wedding oh my
goodness thank you so much mom I totally
forgot about these many as when it was
the time of the wedding I'm so glad that
you saved it for me
oh man this is such a nice surprise to
remember the menus from the wedding yeah
I have a surprise for you too what is it
well you go get it all right mom look at
what my grandma had you waiting my
wedding invitation she kept it and it
looks brand-new it looks like it was
just printed yesterday Oh a lot of
memories those memories you know make me
tear up a little bit because I was
really happy that day Oh mom I was
pregnant of you I was four months
pregnant I know it was a shotgun wedding
he wants to check in with me yes this
invitation means a lot to me and I think
I did meet a lot to you so keep it along
isn't that crazy you bring me my my
wedding menu and then I bring you your
wedding invitation let me give them a
close-up here in the front that's my mom
and dad first the middle name and then
this is what the inside looks like and
it's so crazy because they got married
July 22nd 1989 and we in Casey's wedding
was July 27 2017 I almost forgot oh yeah
this is so cool I'm glad you like it
I still have the first thing you gave me
here oh yeah about you this and parents
remember in that subway what is it oh
yeah the Metro Metro you know this lady
tried to put their hand inside on my
purse yeah she honest try pickpocketing
you pocket and I said she run away right
away that was so crazy because I was
coming from Disneyland like we just
spent the whole day at Disneyland we're
all like on this hi
and then I don't know where my mom is
like this lady just try pickpocketing me
oh my god I was like you see mom I told
you you gotta be vigilant so I bought
her that purse before that happened
because the whole pickpocketing thing
was with this person but I'm like man
I'm so glad I got to that person she
didn't get anything I know because she
tried to open it but since the zipper
inside you know yeah you get into it so
I'm almost about to take a bite out of
the oatmeal cookies that I made and I'll
think wait wait I got a like this I want
to see her reaction soon she likes it so
pumpkin oatmeal raisin cookies tell me
what you think okay
mmm they're really soft
Oh nuts walnut walnut yeah
did you know or I didn't know that
walnuts was nice yeah nice I never knew
that in my life I I had to ask Google
and get your life yeah I think you'll
like yeah is it noise walnuts and I'm
like no isn't it pecans I thought they
were pecans my whole life nu s is walnut
and not pecan I never knew that but you
know it's interesting this morning we
asked Google again and then Google says
that pecan is no s picanha noise begun
but as she said noise first I'm like
where's the camera we got a 1 but anyway
I guess it's walnuts right mom
yeah walnut walnut anyways noise wait so
McDonough's or picanha how do you say
goodness how do you say pecans in
Spanish you'll say alright so we just
finished Isaac's project and I am pretty
proud if I do say so myself
so only Isaac and I worked on this which
makes me a little bit even more proud
because the last project keeps me had a
big hand in it because he's very
artistic so yeah I'm proud of this be
proud of it
okay let's show what we got you want to
explain what's happening so this
practice for your two paragraph essay
that you have to write so what's
happening right now is you're pumping
your shiny clean water to the water
tower
look at that and look who's home so
you're ready to spend the night with
Daddy yeah hopefully the calash after
your 1 to 2 paragraph report right yep
the last priorities first yes and then
Han Solo ha'olam
maybe all right mom you're ready to go
partying up go the concert yes all right
vamonos all right so we finally got here
these are the people that were gonna be
perform today comment down below if you
guys know who these people are I've
never heard of these artists but we're
gonna enjoy the show right mom yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we just left the concert would
you think I was awesome yeah you had fun
yes I guess I think I should have done
some homework before coming to this
concert I should actually listen to the
artist and got to know the song there
was just one song that actually did
recognise which was from the first
artist so he saw that guys it's one song
that they played I was like oh I've
heard that one and that was the only one
it was fun I'm just hanging out with my
mom just seeing everybody else enjoy the
song that was just they're eating my red
vines and I'm just like and then eating
some popcorn okay I'll just neck well I
listened to some music but it was really
fun though the nice night like thank you
for the army yeah thanks for inviting me
and having me be the person you brought
after winning these tickets on the radio
[Music]